a traverse across the Arctic ice from
the North Pole to the remote islands
known as franz josef land it was an
almost impossible journey a century ago
and is just as dangerous today in the
late 1800s Norwegian explorers freed HOF
Nansen and hi all Mario Henson took
refuge on franz josef land in a failed
bid for the North Pole now National
Geographic grantees Borga ausland and
Tomas Ulrich are retracing their
predecessors passed to this frigid
outpost these maybe I'll ups but a
vacation it's not
day one the team gets airlifted to the
North Pole between the pole and the
islands of franz josef land ly over 500
miles of Arctic ice they must navigate
the frozen sea by walking skiing
paddle
and sometimes fly with kites
the kiting on the ice I guess was the
most danger part everything goes very
fast and you have to react fast and it
was very danger that you you fell and
you heard yourself or you can break a
leg with a stiff breeze and smooth ice
the team can cover up to 30 miles a day
but when the wind stops or ocean
currents compress the sea ice into
pressure ridges progress slows to one
painful step at a time borghi and Thomas
must retrace their own footsteps far too
often the sledges filled with food
shelter and fuel weigh in at over 350
pounds apiece after more than a month on
the sea ice a welcome sight yah cannot
sleep Viva La Jolla paw filme no Eva
Island the northeastern tip of the
archipelago lands seductively close and
yet maddeningly difficult to get to the
the polar oceans started melting off and
get apart and we
had to fight very difficult sections
like we had a lot of currents we were
almost drifting away from our Island
super strong that's a raucous country
award leaving the open ocean behind the
explorers turn their attention to the
islands but soon they find themselves
amongst some very curious locals I think
we met about 25 or 30 polar bears on
this expedition and some came really
really close and to have a Polaroid
these two three meters away this huge
meat eater with the teats that can crush
you in instant that's a very intense
experience and we came to the certain
parts of the island there was no ice
anymore polar bears that were trapped on
the same islands and so they could go
nowhere for the next month Morga and
Thomas pick their way through the
islands of franz josef land finding
evidence of the Nansen's expedition over
a hundred years earlier the remnants of
Nansen's hut where the explorer
overwintered 47 frozen months preserved
for a century by the cold
finally on day 85 the end of the journey
Cape flora here borghi and Thomas will
meet their ride home a sailboat
dispatched to retrieve them but the
boats not there
they're forced to wait for three more
weeks their food stores all but gone
fortunately Thomas isn't afraid of
heights well supplied with some local
cuisine borghi and thomas had the beach
to themselves at least until the
tourists show up hello there hello hi
Gretchen this is Bob from Los Angeles Oh
Jessica what are you doing here we've
come to see you did you know that you're
the first people we see in in three
months you're killin no delighted are
not so delighted oh we are feeling we
are exciting I understand that in a
rapidly shrinking and changing world it
seems no place is too remote for a
summer holiday finally as the Arctic
summer winds a sail on the horizon they
paddle out to meet their boat for borghi
and Thomas the journey took just over
100 days
if you form come on Vern Anson it took
three years a century apart and a very
different world
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium